wir stehen zusammen mit den klitschko
brüdern in kiel nachdem wir vor drei
tagen mittlerweile vitali ausputzer
zurückgekommen sind am sonntag warst du
dort wird ihr dort und habe durch das
grauen angeschaut sind die bilder noch
im kopf hast du albträume davon die
leichen die dort auf den straßen stand
unser gefühl ich habe sehr viel in
meinem leben gesehen aber alles ruhig
erlebt
das war
meine
man kann sehen dass es
zerstörte stadt
und am meisten hat mich gern gerückt
seien negative sind das ist die leichen
von zivilisten und
lächeln funktion ist er
unschuldig
zu wissen wer hat fahrrad gefahren bei
schossen fußgänger war erschossen sogar
genommene mit gebundenen händen berühren
war
kopf geschossen
das war das war schrecklich und möchte
keine sorgen dass sein puls motor
das ist richtig das war
mir was ist dir im kopf geblieben von
diesem besuch dort wir waren ja mehrere
stunden in botschaft und hast du das
gefühl dass die welt verstanden hat und
dass die welt jetzt wirklich die
konsequenzen zieht die gezogen werden
müssten aus eurer sicht
diese folge war eine klare message
von russland das ist folter und es gibt
nichts anderes wir wollen euch züchter
wir werden unser stellen wir bleiben die
stehen wir werden weiter rollen nichts
was du es anhalten wird
diese brutalität ist es kein zufall
in mehreren städten passiert das gleiche
provisionen
im osten des markus wollmann mit fonds
verbunden
und cluster banken und diesen verboten
bei der internationalen
und es ist ganz klar an die bevölkerung
also dass das die dass das leben zu
starten und deswegen
diese message ist so klar wie nicht
anders es ist wirklich seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg seit der hitler zeit seitdem
geht von nationen was wir und die welt
erlebt habe auf einmal das von so
genannten brust bruder folgt russland
erleben wir sind keine unglaublich es
ist es ist es ist nicht mitwirken zu
beschreiben was passiert im waldecker
ist
gut für uns ist es ist einfach etwas hab
mich noch verrückt
danach
ausgelesen berufung sagen dass es ein
fake das alles installiert speziellen zu
zeigen
so eine reihe von marcus seidel stand
vor der leiche gesehen den man mit den
händen nach hinten verbunden die ein
schlüssel unten die leiche war bestimmt
mehr als eine woche alt
mehr als eine woche kannte man
erschossen und haben dort gelegt aber
die blut gesehen
und muss sagen dass es stimmt nicht dass
es nicht wenigen der ukraine hat alles
inszeniert das war richtig hierüber
würden nach solchen informationen
wladimir und trotzdem ist es so dass die
jetzt sagt kohle nicht mehr exportieren
aus oder nicht mehr importieren aus
russland das gibt ein exportverbot für
kohle aber an öl und gas will man weiter
nicht ran das macht das mit euch das
embargo für öl und gas kohle und alles
andere muss staaten
muss stattfinden es gibt keinen anderen
weg als mustern zu isolieren ohne
isolierung wird russland dieses
vernichten von der krise und nicht nur
ihre propaganda hat schon angekündigt
dass die chronisten der anfang und wenn
das nicht gemacht wird dann wird das
zweite georg uns jede handel mit
russland auf jeder ebene mit jedem
produkt heißt es im mehr geld für den
krieg in ihrem budget haben werden
vitali jetzt erleben wir dass ich hier
langsam wieder auch mal steht kann man
fast sagen also einzelnen checkpoints
werden weggeräumt ich habe schon erste
restaurants gesehen die wieder öffnen
wann wird hier wieder richtiges leben
herrschen wie lange dauert das noch und
wie fürsorge hast du was jetzt im osten
bis jetzt das noch
normales leben
hier muss noch viel zeit ins leben zu
kommen weil die leute kommen jeder wohl
wieder nach hause kommen auch draußen im
see statt mit
webos
risiko noch
raketenattacke und bombardierungen steht
noch ziemlich groß und deswegen meine
man sich für alle weil wollen zurück zu
kommen und die nie so schnell noch eine
woche abwarten und weil
wir sind auch verantwortlich für die
lieben das leben das wollte das ist das
was mich reizt kommen aber trotzdem so
lernen die
kleine von hochreinem unsere stadt hat
keine sicherheit was erwartest du was
jetzt im osten passiert hat gibt es
bereits berichte über eine einkesselung
im donbass dass die russische armee
versucht dort ukrainische soldaten
einzukesseln und zur aufgabe zu zwingen
wie gefährlich wird das für die ukraine
dort ist gefährlich berufsjahre mischung
versucht den fang an zu essen
sind geschafft glaubt weil unsere partei
hat der russische pläne
zerstört
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bestimmt die ganze armee das rad um
gestanden jetzt im moment nach osten
durch eine gezogen
[Musik]
wir waren eine richtige schlacht um
deswegen dass wir jetzt noch ein noch
einmal wiederholen wir brauchen
beteiligungs waffen weil verteidigen
weil wir verteidigung unserer gegend
adresse
das ist schwierige zeit die
diesen krieg
und wir wissen nicht wie lernen genau
wisse nicht wie viele opfer dieser krieg
wird aber gerade mit bürgermeister von
ringier getroffen aber ich mit ihm
gesprochen
jetzt schon
400 zivilisten gestorben und
fast
200 noch vermisst das
bedeutet die wahrscheinlich dass es mehr
als 1000 menschen das zivilisten
gestorben in dieser stadt geht er davon
aus dass es mehrere botschaft in der
ukraine gibt also mehrere orte wo das
passiert ist was wir alle dort gesehen
haben
absolut wir rechnen mit dem schlimmsten
das was wir bis jetzt den date haben
heißt noch nicht dass wir alles gesehen
haben und auch die ranglisten nicht
alles gesehen haben weil es gibt viele
orte ukraine ist
ziemlich gut besetzt mit
dass mit dem leben wo die mit dem
kleinen roten kleinen dorf und es steht
natürlich in der nächsten daten noch
mehr aus und das kann ich so listen
deswegen habe man keine informationen
zum glück sehr viel ehrende in der es um
einen journalisten die sich in gif und
deswegen
schnell die journalisten berichten
wahrheit und bitte kriegen was passiert
und wir wissen nicht wirklich was in
kleine dorf ein kleines stelle passiert
letzte frage was erwartet ihr von dem
besuch von eu kommissionspräsident
ursula von der leyen die hat in dieser
woche
nachkommen will was erwartet wir
erwarten weil ich schon verstoßen das
ist sehr wichtig für uns wir gedanken an
alles was hat deutschland gibt dann aber
draußen wir brauchen mehr wir brauchen
mehr verteidigungswaffen weil ich noch
einmal bestätigen verteidigungs war von
wald beteiligung über eine verteidigung
unser land und sie ist kein geheimnis
ist charme der stadt ich habe sehr viel
raketen ich habe sehr viele sehr gut
ausgerüstet
ist und deswegen
wir brauchen mal gerne waffen zu
beteiligen und noch dazu sehr wichtig
hierbei musste stehen und wir beteiligen
nicht nur unsere städte nicht nur unsere
familie wie verteidigen gemeinsamen
europäischen demokratische werte und das
bedeutet wir kämpfen auch nicht nur für
die reine für die ganze demokratische
welt aber gleichzeitig würde ich mir
auch die frage an dich das fordert er ja
eigentlich seit beginn des krieges mehr
waffen und immer noch ist nichts
passiert das muss einfach wahnsinnig
machen oder
was es wahnsinnig macht ist diese vision
um das versprechen die westliche welt
wären russland über die grenze geht ohne
in version von den grünen macht dann
werden harte konsequenzen kommen das hat
bei den beiden gesagt es haben alle
westliche politiker gesagt bis jetzt
sieben wochen des krieges die harte
konsequenzen ziehen wir und wir bekommen
das wir komplette infrastruktur zur
störung haben und vor allem
zivilisten werden nahtlos vernichtet und
das geht gerade werden für dieses
interview machen das passiert auch im
süden im osten des landes wo ganz
schrecken verlaufen das kann doch nicht
wahr sein dass man als nachbar anschaut
und ich würde natürlich unterstützung
was gerade wieder links hat man danke an
das westliche welt an diese freiheit
danke für die unterstützung aber es ist
nie genug vergleich mit dem was wir
bisher erlebt haben mit dieser
akquisition und seelische kraft was wir
als unterstützung bekommen haben ist
viel zu wenig es ist nicht zu
vergleichen mit dem verlust postiert war
erlebt haben und die konsequenz mussten
kommen nicht nur mit worten nie dass es
schön aussieht mit mit den funktionen
die eigentlich keinem wehtun
ich bin dafür dass deutschland
eigentlich als leader in europa stellt
und letztendlich zähne zeigt wo es nicht
an einer aggression oder
wo ist ja nicht wie sie zumindest eine
grüne passiert war gestoppt und zwar hat
bald deutschland ist eine geschichte
lernen in europa ist es sind da witali
klitschko herzlichen dank ladentisch und
damit zurück nach berlin